many of our clients are actually
surprised when they come to the garage
for their first visit or for our
workshop that we don't talk a lot about
technology you would think we would wear
the IBM garage but in fact we always are
focusing on solutioning sooner we don't
start with technology we start with the
user needs and I'm a technologist myself
I'm a techie and sorry it sometimes
pains me to step back from the
technology and customers sometimes have
have the same challenge what are the
end-user pain points where is the
opportunity the big idea to improve
these end-users lives in whatever way it
may be and we start from that in the
garret we have a set of practices that
we found allow clients to get the most
out of the cloud so these are Lean
Startup hypothesis driven development
devil agile co-creation tener
programming all of these practices are
really important it doesn't work to take
all of these practices in one great love
and then dump them on an organization
we're adaptive in how we work with an
organization to adopt these practices
when we come out of a Design Thinking
workshop we've got a one-sentence
definition of what we're gonna build
next what customers often ask us is how
do I go from this one sentence to
something that that's gonna be real and
sometimes the answer can be really
unexpected a minimal Viable Product and
take different forms
we have a bias towards doing production
pilots and the reason for that is that
is the highest validity user feedback
that you can get if you go and ask
someone would you like this cool app
they'll say sure but you don't really
know whether they will use it until you
give them a capability and you say use
it it's all about testing the hypothesis
what IBM cloud and the associated
services give us in the context of the
innovation that we do is speed it gives
us these great services that are going
to accelerate that are giving us natural
language processing that are giving us
analytics capability that's giving us
compute that's giving us databases fit
for purpose for the type of data
analysis we want to do and having those
in the public cloud and the private
cloud allow us to go really fast
technology is the enabler of innovation
it is not the driver of the innovation